hi I'm Emily Tunnel a research associate
with PETA thanks for stopping by my
poster when I was in graduate school for
neuroscience the forced swim test is
something that would come up in
discussions about as an example of an
animal behavioral test that was often
used to draw incorrect or at best
specious conclusions about an animal's
mood if you're unfamiliar with the for
swim test it was popularized by Roger /
salt it's also called the pour salt swim
test in the late 70s so in this test a
small animal typically a mouse or rat
also sometimes a gerbil hamster or
guinea pig it's placed into a cylinder
that's been filled with water
of course the animal will swim around
furiously try to climb up the sides of
the tank dive to the bottom to try to
find an escape but eventually they will
stop swimming and just start floating
her salt notice that when an animal was
acutely dosed with a tricyclic
antidepressant compounds which were used
at the time and are still used today
that they would struggle for longer
before stopping to float so this lit led
him to interpret floating as a sign of
depression or what he called behavioral
despair since acute administration of an
antidepressant compound would reduce the
amount of time the animals spent
floating since that time that that
interpretation has stuck with a lot of
people and the for swim test has made an
appearance in thousands of publications
and in an FDA investigation on new drug
applications for antidepressant
compounds also since that time a lot of
people have argued that floating is not
a sign of behavioral despair at all but
it's actually a positive trait for
survival animals that stopped swimming
and float for longer are saving their
energy they're adapting to their
situation others have noted really the
overall concept that this very simple
behavioral readout can in no way stand
for the chronic subjective emotional
state of human depression
so due to this controversy we wanted to
know how often pharmaceutical companies
these are entities whose bottom line
depends on turning out successful
therapeutics have used the for swim test
and if their use of it had resulted in
the successful marketing of
antidepressant drugs so we chose four
very well-known pharmaceutical companies
Abbott Labs which is a V which is
formerly Abbott Labs bristol-myers
Squibb Eli Lilly and Pfizer we looked on
PubMed and Google Scholar to locate any
published papers or patent applications
where they presented forced swim test
data we then used we went through those
publications and identified each
compound that was used in for swim tests
we then used these same databases as
well as clinical trials.gov
to follow these compounds through their
development to see had they gone on to
be tested in human depression what's
what sort of happened so in our research
with these four companies we identified
forty seven compounds that were given to
almost 5,000 animals that were used in
for swim tests by these four companies
only 14 of these compounds which you'll
see in the gray table on my poster 14 of
these compounds that reduced immobility
in the fourth swim test which means by
that conclusion they should have some
efficacy for human depression 14 of
these 14 have also been tested in human
depression so then we asked you know
what what did these human tests show did
the four swim test was the four swim
tests correct and predicting that they
were efficacious and are these compounds
currently used as successful human
antidepressants the result was that no
none of the 14 compounds are currently
marketed as as antidepressants and used
by humans only three of them showed to
be efficacious for human depression
three of them are still undergoing
clinical trials
and the remaining 11 compounds we found
that the foursome test was not
predictive of how of the efficacy of
these drugs for human depression so
that's definite 11 out of the 14 I'm
sorry so that's 8 out of the 14 that
were absolutely nada fication 3 you're
still pending so that's at least a 57
percent chance of the force one test
giving a false conclusion that's higher
than chance I'm flipping a coin of the
three compounds that did reduce the
mobility in the porcelain test and were
efficacious for human depression they
are not currently marketed because of
other side effects that most of which
were not predicted by the preclinical
animal experiments so this is a very
small sample size for companies 12 out
of 47 compounds but we're doing more
work in this area and we and we hope to
publish this data soon but if further
data corroborate these findings that the
for swim test is less predictive than
chance at saying whether or not a
compound could be efficacious for human
depression then we argue that there
would be very little reason for
pharmaceutical companies to continue to
use the for swim test the reason for the
FDA to consider it as a viable test in
new drug applications or really little
reason that for it to be used in basic
behavioral research when the for swim
tests animals are subjected to the
terror of near drowning and many have
drowned in these tests due to
inattentive experimenters or in early
versions of the test when before I
Eclipse they didn't really have to
rescue the animals from the situation
but so it's it's cruel at its base but
it really misleads drug development and
in turn doesn't help suffering patients
so if you'd like to learn more about
this I'd love to talk to you about it
you can reach me at Emily T at PETA org
thanks so much